dix rencontres et un président de la
république ici ou là qui vous mitterrand
mitterrand a way alors il vous avez quoi
rien mais jaffe la story j'ai été très
impressionné en scène tout petits
n'étaient pas légion d'honneur oui c'est
à l'élysée pour ça les autres et sarkozy
sarkozy ray dernière garden party vous
avez dit on parle et on est dans le
jardin et vous tenez le jardinier vous
jure que c'est vrai abandonné l'appui
finir juste six personnes dans l'elysée
way dont moi non mais certains analystes
dont brahim n'étiez pas seul c'est votre
c'est votre ami et avec d'autres amis en
être connus au début du groupe de gens
que nous envoyer vos qui nous a choisis
avec des gens connus jaunies des
sandales mois à la maison je la veille
avec fogiel chazal mois puis deux ou
trois autres je suppose qu'elle a dû
faire clair marco l'air parcours venir
oui je ne sais pas qui c'est mais qui
viennent également il est venu vers moi
et m'a serré la main il m'a dit qu'elle
voulait sarkozy non ah ouais bah vous
saviez qu'il s'était oui voilà
nécessaire et noble et s'est présenté ce
que vas-tu de lambeaux de ouf
non j'ai dit matthieu delormeau il m'a
répondu je sais et j'aime beaucoup ce
que vous il m'a dit bon je n'ai refusé
un poste de ministre de la défense